kommandoübergabe bei der vierten
panzergrenadierbrigade im
oberösterreichischen hörsching wo man
dann wenn sie dann noch mal die 1500 ps
hören kommt ein bisschen wehmut auf
selbstverständlich gibt es auch etwas
mehr mut nach dem abschnitt nach
zweieinhalb jahren das war sehr sehr
schöne zeit dass er sehr herausfordernde
zeit die auch mit einigem stolz
verbunden ist
aber nach einer gewissen zeit geht das
leben weiter und der nächste verwendung
wartet
[Musik]
also ich glaube es ist für die karriere
jedes profitiert und die soldaten ein
höhepunkt der brigade führen zu dürfen
und stellt sicherlich auf dem höhepunkt
meiner laufbahn
damit einher geht eine tiefe
verbundenheit mit der vergabe
selbstverständlich dass wir gerne liegt
mir am herzen wir uns eng verbunden
bleiben und die hinter sich natürlich
auch in zukunft um die entwicklung und
um die geschicke der vierten partie
darüber gar nicht verdenken wenn das
immer anderen wird der panzerbrigade
wird und diese geschicke liegen ab
sofort in seinen händen brigadier
magister sieht waldtieren ich war ja
bereits als junger offizier nach der
ausmusterung fünf jahre in ried im
innkreis mansfeld und 13 stationiert
kenne daher oberösterreich gesamt
bereits recht gut und daher denke ich
dass die situation oberösterreich
derzeit keine großen überraschungen für
mich mehr bieten sollte sondern allen
bekannt sein könnte kann darüber gab es
schon immer besondere anlässe natürlich
auch die leistungen da hier vierten bahn
sagt renate brigade zu würdigen und
natürlich auch in die zukunft zu blicken
und da wünsche ich dem neuen
kommandanten brigadier alles erdenklich
gute glaube er ist der richtige mann am
richtigen ort
er ist nicht nur hoch qualifiziert
sondern hat auch die richtige
soldatischen wertingen sich genau das
braucht es auch
[Musik]